welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video we're
breaking down the post-credit scenes of
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3. the movie
ends by closing the book on certain
things whilst also setting up a possible
future with the Guardians down the line
I want to get straight into it but if
you're one of them Chumps or clicks to
post credit scene video and complaints
about spoilers I don't know how much
more I can spell it out mate channels
call heavy spoilers stop being a [__]
idiot you know they told me you people
were conceited douchebags but that isn't
true at all
now without the way thank you for
clicking the video now let's get into
the post credit scene no matter what I
bet Ryan wouldn't talk to you like that
we'll all fly away together
forever
[Music]
and beautiful sky
[Applause]
foreign
culminates with the Guardians beating
the high evolutionary and deciding to
somewhat go their separate ways Manta
sets off on her own Journey with three
of the monsters at the group board at
the beginning of volume 2. Drax and
Nebula look after the kids on nowhere
Gamora goes back to her home with the
ravages and we see a new Guardians team
being formed this includes rocket
Raccoonus and you leader and alongside
her Mrs buddy King Groot craglin Cosmo
the space dog Adam Warlock and phylaval
I'm gonna get an all these later on but
in them we watch them protecting a
village with some aliens that I think
Peter slept with in the first film and
this is again some alien monster animals
before the fight begins we hear them
talking about their favorite songs and
Rocket plays come and get your love by
Redbone
we can also see that while wearing the
brand new Guardians uniform and we close
out the scene by watching them running
towards the camera now you know I like
to keep up to date on plot leaks and a
couple of months ago this scene was
actually spoiled but it had one key
difference in it in the spoilers the
group were called the annihilators and
if we look at the comics then they could
be doing a similar thing with them that
group was formed as part of the Thanos
imperative and it's possible that they
could tie Adam Warlock in with this in
the comic the group were put together to
stop the Big Bad Bull chin Baddie but
with him being on the picture they might
alter things to incorporate Warlock and
a couple of other people no three times
but I think that Eros and the eternals
might be brought into it too when Harry
Styles popped up at the end of that
movie A lot of people were wondering how
they'd integrate him into the story due
to his brother being dead and so on and
so forth pip the trolls also a big Ally
of Adam Warlock and to be honest I was
quite surprised to scene with Eros and
not him however they could end up
integrating these two teams together for
a movie Down on the line and we have to
bear in mind that Thor and lover out
there as well at the end of love and
then now we watched as the pair were
doing good in the galaxy and it's
possible I could bring them together
into one big team beta right bill is
part of the annihilators as well and we
may get a space team up involving him
Thor and love along with the Guardians
that becomes as Guardians of the Galaxy
and that's all one big theme
but with James gun jumping ship to DC I
think that the entire Direction the
Guardians are going in needs to heavily
change and they'll probably incorporate
other elements of the MCU in order to
keep the characters going now the new
members of the team could also hand out
what's happening with the other
properties and I've been talking to
YouTuber Austin Medeiros about where we
think things will be going definitely
check out his channel if you're into
comic book movies as he's got lots of
great content over there and you know me
I love shouting out the up and coming
creators because I'm just a nice guy
that also owns 95 of the channel
anyway philavel actually pulls from the
greater Marvel Universe and she was the
Captain Marvel of her reality depending
on what version you read though you're
gonna get a different origin story and
now we have 616 Visions you also have
ones that come from Earth one eight
eight nine seven so it's not possible to
say exactly what her origin story is
however with this being the main
Universe the main one that we follow is
possibly the one tied in with the 616
reality during the annihilation event
there's a word again filo is attacked by
Thanos and she eventually teamed up with
Nova and Star-Lord to battle against
denialis she also clashed with Galactus
who according to rumors has been cast as
Antonio Banderas I'm guessing that he's
going to be showing up in the new
Fantastic full movie and we may have all
these elements branching off from there
and tying into this greater Cosmic
Universe part of the MCU I think it
would be smart to unite all these
elements together and with bala being a
version of Captain Marvel she made time
with a Marvel's movie coming in November
that's seeing different people all Unite
with a similar sort of power set so I
think it would make sense to tie them
all in created by the high evolutionary
Vila has powers that allow her to tap
into purple energy and we know from the
Marvel color code that this aligns her
with dark energy in case you don't know
every energy color in the MCU is tied in
with certain properties which is why we
see the red with one disabilities time
with reality which is showcased in the
redness that the reality Stone possesses
cosmic energy is golden which is why we
see the eternals in Captain Marvel
carrying it and so on and so forth again
purple is dark which ties in with
characters like do Mamu and agate the
Harkness along with another little girl
the same age as phyla that is of course
love from Love and thunder and with them
being a similar age group again I could
see something where they pull these
characters in the same storyline to
unite the cosmic Universe at the moment
though we don't have a movie like that
plan in the MCU and after the Marvels
there's not really anything that could
time with the cosmic stuff and telkang
Dynasty we do know however that the
Fantastic Four will probably explore
space and this is down mainly to their
Origins if practice and dwbs in that
then they'd need more than the Fantastic
Four to take him down and this could
cool together all aspects of the space
side of things for this gigantic threat
when we're talking big bads in the
Marvel Universe he's definitely someone
who fits the bill and after Kang he may
be the next in line I don't even think
the heroes of Earth would be capable of
standing against him so having a team
out in space that unites all the cosmic
ones makes the most sense to me so
that's where I see things going with
rocket leading the team then potentially
coming across the Eternal Thor the
Marvels and so on as they make their way
through the universe anyway I want to
talk about the second post credit scene
next first just a quick word from our
sponsors spoiler alert I'm not as young
as I used to be we're all getting old
and I'm sure many of you out there can
relate you know you have a great night
out but the next day it completely
knocks you out I don't bounce back the
way that I used to and it's gotten to
the point that I can either choose to
have a great night out or have a great
day the next one that is until I found
biotics Zed biotics pre-alcohol
probiotic is the world's first
genetically engineered probiotic it was
invented by PhD sinus to tackle rough
mornings after drinking here's how it
works when you drink it alcohol gets
converted into a toxic byproduct in the
gut it's this byproduct not dehydration
that's the blame for your rough next day
however Zed biotics produces an enzyme
to break down this byproduct it's
designed to work like your liver but in
your gut where you need it most just
remember to drink Zed biotics before
drinking alcohol drink responsibly and
get a good night's sleep to feel your
best tomorrow every time I drink it it
makes such a difference to the next day
most times you know I can't be bothered
with that workout in the morning however
having that I just push through it
because I feel so much better there's
lots of bank holiday weekends
approaching in England I know Memorial
Day weekends happening in America so
make sure you stock up on zedbiotics for
you and your friends go to
zedbiotics.com heavy spoilers to get 15
off your first order when you use the
code heavy spoilers at checkout you can
also sign up for a subscription using my
code so you can stay prep no matter the
time or occasion zbiotics is also backed
by a 100 money back guarantee so if you
have any issues with it they'll refund
your money no questions asked remember
to click the link in the description and
go to zbiotics.com heavy spoilers and
use the code heavy spoilers at checkout
for 15 off huge thank you to zedbiotics
for sponsoring this video and I'll see
you in the rest of the breakdown now the
second post credit scene brings things
full circle from the opening of the
first Guardians movie I need to talk
about the film's ending in order to give
context to this as it builds off the
back of the final few scenes which won't
make sense if I don't ramble on for
three minutes about what happens with
quill now at the end we see Star-Lord
going back to his grandfather's home who
he's not seen since he was abducted all
those years ago his grandfather's new
wife opens the door which initially
makes him believe that he's at the wrong
place but upon asking if Mr quills about
she then says yes going into the
backyard he sees his grandfather and
from this point the pair hug it out it's
kinda similar to Steve meeting back up
with Peggy at the end of end game not
like that but this is the home and life
that he should have had however he was
called on to do greater things now
though quill returned to Earth by the
events of endgame he ended up leaving
rather than going home in a lot of our
videos on these films I've often taken
this as being because of how traumatic
it was to be back on Earth where his
mother died this gets confirmed in the
film when Gamora suggests he goes back
because in the end he doesn't really
have a home with her if you've ever lost
someone through a shocking circumstance
and you'll know how difficult it is to
pass through the place where they died
and it makes sense that he'd want to get
out there as quickly as he could now
though he's ready to return home and be
back with the family that loved and
missed him they likely had no idea what
happened to him all those years ago and
he's ready to take some time to be with
them and possibly restore his life on
Earth unfortunately due to this movie's
Gamora going off he likely won't end up
with her there is potential down the
line which will talk more on in just a
bit it but I do think the pair are
destined not to be together the Gamora
he loved he ended up losing an Infinity
war and no matter how much he tries to
force things the one who came over just
as in hair rather than relying on that
variant to make him Holo he's now found
in a piece and realized that he has a
home back on Earth where he'll be loved
and accepted this is kind of how I take
the ending and rather than trying to
make those things that don't work work
he's going somewhere where the pieces
all fit together naturally anyway the
second post credit scene opens on Peter
and his grandpa eating cereal and we get
nice little reference to the holiday
special joking catches Grandad reading a
newspaper with a headline talking about
how Kevin Bacon was abducted by aliens
you also get the idea that Peter is
trying to avoid doing his chores like
mowing the lawn but if you've seen how
he [__] up the plan to remove thanos's
Gauntlet mate I wouldn't even let him
water the plants never forget your [__]
now from here we fade out and we get the
text on screen saying the legendary
Star-Lord will return it's a big
question leaving the theater is Pro
probably of this line of text Brad of
course has the potential to follow gun
to DC and there are a lot of things up
in the air at the moment and the first
way to take it is at face value with
this meaning that Peter Quill will be
called back in the fight and that will
follow his adventures down the line
potentially he could end up running into
Gamora in a couple of years and the pair
may fall in love the legendary Star-Lord
is also a term using Peter Quill's solo
comic book series Without likely being a
nod to him coming back under that name
if brat was coming back then I think
they'd likely save it for a big story
like Secret Wars and if you've read the
comic then you'll know the Earth gets
transformed into battle World which is a
mash of all realities heavily pulls in
the 616 which Peter is of course a
member of unless it makes sense that he
could be brought across with this now
tying into Secret Wars means that they
could also do something else unlike the
other Marvel movies a text appears at
the end on a white background instead of
a black one this could show that we
might have a similar Star-Lord to what's
come before though there could be
something different about him
potentially the Multiverse being open
means that we could get another
Star-Lord and they made you a variant
for that film and potentially even
recast the character going forward in
the MCU Zoe Saldana has been very open
about hopping Gamora is recast and she's
recently been giving interviews talking
about this directly from what I've been
told about the plans of Secret Wars
where heading for a sort of soft reboot
that brings in multiple aspects of the
expanded Marvel Universe and unites them
into one reality there's also going to
be some new versions of old characters
so they can keep things the same without
the actors aging out of roles so yeah
those are the ways that I think things
could be going in the future and I hope
you enjoy the breakdown on the two
scenes we will be back with a more
detailed one coming either tomorrow or
Friday so keep an eye out for that at
some point now in the meantime I'd love
to hear your thoughts on the film so
make sure you drop them in the comments
section below also we just launched a
new shirt over at Zero edition and if
you want to support the channel then
definitely head over there right after
this all the money goes towards helping
me me Ryan area Craig from real rejects
not have to get proper jobs and you know
what we're very proud of the designs
that we've come up with inspired by lots
of Pop Culture things the fabric is also
very high quality can promise you that
and they've been designed so that the
clothing is actually flattering to your
body so you don't look like some kind of
chump I love wearing them pretty much
every day I wear some of my own stuff
and it's that good so yeah definitely
head over there help support the channel
keeps the lights on and also makes you
look good so it's a no lose situation if
not though and you want something free
we are running competition right now and
giving away the quantumania steel Buck
to three subscribers on the 15th of May
all you have to do to be when the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the film you pick the comments at
random on the 15th and the winners of
the last one are on screen right now
save that to you then message me on
Twitter at heavy spoilers Beyonce meals
to watch so make sure you check out one
of our breakdowns on screen now and
hopefully I see you over at another one
because you've just hit subscribe and
you made if not then
yeah but uh yeah I'll see you see you on
the next one later on in the week you
take care peace